[Music]
how do you balance
being the guy that america calls when
they're struggling with something
and then the guy at home how do you
shift and navigate
hey all these people are asking for my
advice and your 14 year old is just like
hey how would you shut up old man and
yeah let me you know what i mean how do
you how do you balance that
well i haven't i haven't done a good job
of it and you know that what does that
mean
oh i just i'm recently awakening to the
fact that i've been parenting my kids as
a coach because i love sports
yeah you know so i i i played sports my
whole life
i always matriculated to the coach who
was kind of the tough love yeah
i knew my coach loved me yeah but he'd
bust my butt and he was tough and i
responded well
to people who pushed me yeah um
and then i'm learning about fear of the
fear of a father
what's that mean well it's the fear of
the mother too
but for me what it means is is that you
have this
dream of being a parent which i did and
our journey was very different and
all over the place as you know and you
finally become a parent and you just
want to invest and pour into these kids
that you love
so much you can't even possibly
articulate it
and you go along and then they don't
turn out
maybe the way you expect it or they
don't do things you expected
and it's just the normal rhythm we're
not talking about major stuff here and
you begin to get controlling because
you're like well i'm afraid that they
may not do this i'm afraid that they
don't
and and then then you combine that
with this i can
coach i can i can show you i can teach
you
i can convince you i can influence you
to do what i know is best for you
yeah and i'm passionate about it yeah i
got bigger muscles in you like
i can make you do this and so what
happens is it
i do believe it it started in the right
place from the heart yep
but then it comes out of the heart
starts making yeah this is this is
really
not uh science but i'm gonna describe
this way it comes from the heart
somewhere it gets up here into the brain
before it comes out my mouth and it
turns into coaching and controlling and
it's
and and it's been hard because
you can't parent with platitudes
it's really easy for me to do that yeah
i'm just being really wrong
and what i'm i've had to stop being a
coach and i gotta start being a dad and
it's still a work in progress
i'm making progress with my kids but i
had to stop
coaching them and i had to just be how's
that feel
i i i'm a 100 and
but you're a counselor do you find that
you naturally move to the counselor role
so they wish i did they beat that out of
you in grad school okay
you cannot treat your they'll tell you
it's unethical and we will hope to find
out
and we'll take your license from you
that's good if you counsel
yeah your friends or your family you
can't have them as clients that's not
your job
it's not your job to counsel your wife
or your kids
but i default to coach and what i
realized was it was less of a moral
failure and more
i i thought i had way more tools and i
thought that
i've i've come to liking baseball
and fishing and hunting because those
are the three greatest things
and anyone who with a rational brain oh
and old punk bands too
anyone with a brain will understand that
those are the four things you should
spend your time and energy on and if
someone i love there yet well i'm all
right but if i'm my kid
i think oh my son is
super into 90s country and i don't have
a psychology for this
yeah and that's right i thought you know
what i just haven't explained it right
i went and bought cds we would take road
trips where i
i found myself trying to convince a
nine-year-old that he should be liking
this over this
and it's an exact same that's that's
what i was describing is that they may
just have they don't react the way to me
that i wanted them to react to me and
all of a sudden i'm projecting my
needs onto them what turns into like
well have you heard that or heard the
the so it goes bad i know we were gonna
talk about parenting but
uh but you know it's hard that's this
show man it's really hard
it's the hardest thing i'll ever do i
disagree i'm i'm willing to say that
no it's it'll be harder things
so i'm interested i'm not convinced of
that but that's okay how do you
you find yourself coaching my kids are
we talking about find yourself yeah
oh geez we're still there what is what
is your
back pedal mechanism how do you when you
catch yourself
oh uh i'll give you an example that's
good yeah the other day i
um my son was
you know talking about this i he said
hey dad can i take some of your fancy
lures to the creek me and his buddies
we're gonna catch some fish
i said dude there's no chance you can't
catch any fish there none zero it's two
feet of water
and he's like okay but we're gonna go
fishing
can i borrow these and
then i realized my data isn't gonna
solve this problem
i've been fishing a thousand i've been
fishing five thousand times
you will not catch fish in there with
that lure
maybe dad can i you know what yes great
and if you lose them you're paying for
them yeah
and then i get a text on my phone a few
hours later for my wife
anchor me to let you know that you were
wrong and they caught a fish
and it made me it made me happy i was
excited but i
thought when my default setting was oh
that's so awesome i thought
oh that's a lot of therapy because i
would have been pissed
like those guys caught a fish and i
would have been mad at myself and i
would have been ashamed and i would have
been
grumpy and spiral and whatever yeah so
my back pedal
is becoming i wish i could say i do it
all the time but it's getting to the
point where
now i'm empathizing instead of trying to
equip
okay you know that's the coach you want
to meet with the heart not with
more info yeah it's well i'm empathizing
two ways number one i first go did i do
something like that when i was that age
probably probably sometimes worse yeah
um that's the first thing
the second thing is is that uh i want
them to feel
that while i'm not thrilled with their
actions
i'm crazy about them yeah i um
you talk about the bible on this show
yeah can you tell me whatever you want
to on this there's a
there's a well known whether you've ever
been in church or not
if you've ever heard of the parable of
the prodigal son look it up and i've
been in church my whole life as we were
talking
and recently i saw something in that
parable that i've never seen before
so when the prodigal comes back from in
a place of shame he's coming back he's
lost everything he's filthy he's nasty
he's been eating with the pigs
he comes back and the way the parable is
told that jesus tells it
is the father sees the sun coming from
afar off and
he's excited and he welcomes him right
and and i kind of always just kind of
glossed over the rest of the story
because i've always like that's awesome
the father was glad his son was back
but nowhere in the parable does he say
come here give me a hug
i told you so i knew this was going to
happen but i'm glad you're safe
there's none of that in fact it's the
next action
so the father does two things one he
goes to the road to meet his son and he
sticks his arms out and welcomes the son
you're welcome but it's the next step
that i've never seen before
he goes go prepare the finest dinner
we're doing a party that's next level
it's not
unconditional love is your welcome back
right
i don't even know what you call that
we're celebrating
that you're alive and that you're back
we're throwing a party
you burned my money you embarrassed me
in the community
you split my family up and i'm so glad
you let's go have chips in case you're
so glad you're home yeah like
so i was just telling my wife that this
is i've not shared this with anybody
i was just like that's the part that's
so hard
about parenting the love is there yeah
but i never saw the other part
which is i'm gonna show you crazy
reckless crazy reckless grace
and redemption i think it's redemption i
think it's one thing if the father hugs
the dude and goes hey let's go get you a
shower
they threw a party that kid goes from
shame to
what is going on here i don't know dude
i'm running with this oh here's what i
love because that stands up
theologically
that's the way well here's what i love
about it is it's the person who was
spurned who went first
yeah the person in power went first and
often
it wasn't about him he wasn't worried
about what everybody thought there's
where i struggle
i get so hung up in my kids behavior
whatever like what are people gonna
think about me it's like
would you stop it it's not about you you
bonehead it's about them
and i think the father was going i don't
care what anybody thinks
even with his other son in the back
going hey what about me yeah uncle
larry's going i wouldn't have done that
you know uncle larry was in the back of
it
but i don't know about this i've had him
been my boy out i kicked his butt yeah
don't you think
of course and yeah
and we solved it with connection right
i'm gonna draw you
nearer than you could even imagine right
that's so i'm that's trying to be
my back pedal so you're leaning into
yeah as a dad you go first man and it's
in the crazy i do that too can
now i'm thinking about it sometimes i
look at my 11 year old and think
well you did this so when you're ready
to take the first step
it's like what an idiot man caught
myself right
caught myself recently and it's just a
normal it wasn't a big thing this is not
a major fire yeah it was just normal
parent stuff
normal disobedience kind of stuff or
just bad decision
and i caught my i literally said it but
i couldn't get the words back
and it was i'm sorry i failed you
yeah yeah i said that
my kid was like literally like what woke
me up was my kid was like
no you didn't my kid
we're talking about teens that are like
they don't even know they have no sense
and he was like
uh no you didn't it was me
and that's the issue there well
dude i didn't know we were going here we
were talking about some tissue
when i got home and i told my son i've
been
so excited i was wrong i y'all are
really impressed good job catching fish
yeah he gave me a hug oh yeah but
modeling for him
here's what it looks like to say i was
wrong uh i will tell you
some of the biggest breakthroughs for me
uh is watching my kids respond to me
going i totally blew it
yeah yeah sorry like i i don't even have
a good excuse
i blew it here yeah and i can't think of
a greater gift other than food and water
and treating our spouses with dignity
yeah it's a great point by the way this
is good this is
good for your marriage it is for your
parenting i mean this is the same kind
of stuff here so
it's a good at workplace when you go in
oh yeah i go into dave and say hey man i
said this
i didn't mean to say it this way i'm
sorry and i mean i can't tell you how
many times i've had to
literally walk into a co-worker with a
plate of steaming crow
[Laughter]
cut it up in front of him and go i'm
going to eat this in front of you
i got to tell you but it's liberating
because
here's the whole thing let's circle back
to some stuff here yeah for people that
are watching here and because
you're talking to people that feel like
they've failed beyond repair
that is such bs there's no you didn't
fail i mean you may have failed but
you're not beyond responsibility you you
failed yeah you screwed up bad but
you're not beyond redemptive
you learned to eat the crow and you
learned to see redemption on the other
side of eating crow
i'm telling you the greatest lessons are
when we're willing to just
eat that dirty that's when i can
untether my ego from
i it's not that i have to be perfect
it's the image of having to be perfect
if i can unhook from that
you're free forcing to confront your
failure makes it hurt
even more than you already thought like
you know what i'm saying
it's enough for you to go oh geez i just
really screwed up and hurt somebody
that's your own recognition but then
when you gotta go to them
it's like that's like a screwdriver in
an open wound
am i right yeah it hurts to own it to
them but here's what happens
to me as you know it leads to healing
it's freedom yeah
but but it's also like i don't want to
feel that much more yeah